alright let's talk about college in
education this week perhaps the best way
to dive into this discussion is to first
tell you guys a bit about my own
personal experience I went to public
school in Long Island from kindergarten
through high school and then on to
Binghamton University New York actually
has a pretty great college system for
decades and since I was a resident
tuition was discounted to just a
fraction of what most colleges cost now
I got a solid education at an affordable
public school and have used my degree in
political science to do exactly what you
all tuned in to see me do now it was my
education that led me to guiding
conversations about important topics
with interesting people I spent a lot of
time in college smoking pot and
listening to fish but that's another
story for another time this show has
been devoted to discussing ideas that
very concept is rooted in a good
education in which you can question what
you believe this is the number one
reason to go to college to learn how to
think critically when we talk about a
battle of ideas you can only have that
battle when people know what their ideas
are actually based on when we talk about
free speech you can only really talk
about knowing why free speech is
important and what happens to societies
that don't have it when we talk about
the dysfunction of our political process
you can really only understand it if you
know the basic tenants of how it was
designed to work in the first place and
when we talk about the complex issues
facing the Middle East you can really
only understand them if you know the
history of the countries and the people
living there I didn't learn all of these
things in college but the foundation of
having my ideas challenged and learning
new things absolutely was built their
learning is something I try to do on
this show each week and it's why I have
no problem telling you guys I don't know
everything and I don't have all the
answers at this very moment the American
education system and our colleges in
particular are under total assault from
the backwards forces on the Left who
don't want open discussion and would
rather stifle ideas they don't like such
as critiquing a certain religion or
questioning the motives of the social
justice movement because of the
authoritarian crusade to shelter young
people from ideas that might challenge
them we've
created safe spaces where we once had
rigorous debate we now issue trigger
warnings where we once were brave enough
to hear ideas that would make us
uncomfortable the attack on the honest
debate has gotten so bad it is now hard
to tell if this intellectual affliction
is coming from the students or from the
faculty between the professor calling
for muscle to remove press from a
demonstration at the University of
Missouri to students demanding the Dean
be fired at Yale for defending the
freedom of expression to my former
guests my Lilly innopolis being shouted
down while talking about free speech at
Rutgers just two weeks ago the tentacles
of intolerance are taking root at
colleges all across America and it's the
ideas which take root today that will be
the ideas that lead us into the future
that's the real risk here we must be
willing to exercise our free speech more
thoughtfully than to only use it to
prevent other people from exercising
theirs we have a right to free speech in
this country not a right to not be
offended my guest just last week ben
shapiro just had a speech about
conservatism at Cal State University
canceled after leftist activists
protested his presence on campus the
school president said that Ben would be
invited back but as part of a panel when
more diverse views could be heard while
that concept doesn't sound terrible in
and of itself let's really understand
what happened here when the
authoritarians be they on the left or on
the right when they like your views you
can speak freely and there's no need for
counter voices when they don't like your
views well you will be screamed at or
outright cancelled this is dangerous and
it's happening more and more every day I
sat here for over an hour with banner
although I didn't agree with him on
array of topics I listened and I learned
from the response we got on the episode
so did many of you even if all you
learned was that you completely disagree
with him that's what conversations all
about and it's that precious space where
you learn to think on your own which is
exactly what the point of higher
education is supposed to be College is
the single most important place where
ideas must be challenged as I say all
the time let the battle of ideas happen
and the good ones will eventually win by
slandering opponents demanding
professors be fired and cancelling
speaking events
these college kids are unwittingly
strengthening ideas that will one day
silence them eventually the day will
come when they want to say something
that's considered unpopular and they
will then be subjected to the same
practices that they themselves are
propagating right now the second they
leave the safety of their college quad
and are hit with the harsh reality of
the real world
they'll be ill-prepared to deal with
anyone who doesn't share their myopic
view of how things should be to help me
dissect this crisis and that's exactly
what it is is professor GAD sad GAD is
an author professor and evolutionary
behavioral scientist at the John Molson
School of Business at Concordia
University in Montreal Canada GAD is
also a fearless defender of free speech
and an outspoken advocate of free
expression in an academic climate that
doesn't look too kindly on these things
these days we're gonna dive deep into
what has happened at college campuses
all over the world and why free speech
must be defended at all cost once again
get in your safe space you've been
trigger warned let's exercise some of
that free speech while we still have it